soccer fans in england are offering a
wave of support
for three players who missed penalty
kicks in a sudden death shootout
that decided the final match of the
european soccer championship
marcus rashford jaden sancho and bukayo
saka were blasted with racist abuse
online after the game
police are tracking those abusive posts
trying to find the people responsible
others are pointing fingers at top
officials accused of enabling the posts
mts tayub has more from london's wembley
stadium
home of england's national team it was
the moment
england's euro cup championship dreams
came crashing down
now three young black players who missed
their penalty shots
bukayosaka jaden sancho and marcus
rashford
find themselves the targets of online
racism so
vile london's metropolitan police are
investigating
they are incredibly proud of what gareth
southgate manages england's team
for some of them to be abused is
unforgivable really
we i think have been
a beacon of light in bringing people
together
a heartfelt message of unity for
multicultural britain
that critics accused prime minister
boris johnson of trying to divide
at the start of the tournament johnson
refused to condemn fans who
booed england's players for taking a
knee as part of anti-racism protest
with a spokesman saying the prime
minister was quote more focused on
action rather than gestures but after
sunday's final
johnson had this to say to those spewing
racist hate
online shame on you and i hope you will
crawl back
under the rock from which you emerged
almost immediately johnson was accused
of hypocrisy
with england player tyrone mings calling
out a member of his cabinet tweeting
you don't get to stoke the fire at the
beginning of the tournament by
labeling our anti-racism message as
quote gesture politics and then pretend
to be disgusted when the very thing
we're campaigning against
happens any aluko is a former player for
england's national women's team
i don't think they're going to be
sitting there not being proud
it's terrible it needs to change but
ultimately
it doesn't stop us as black people
moving forward
near manchester a mural of marcus
rashford was defaced with racist
graffiti
it was then covered up in tributes to
him and is now being restored
in an emotional tweet he said i can take
critique of my performance
all day long but i will never apologize
for who i
am and where i came from that was mts
taeyab reporting from london it wasn't
all hate online marcus rashford also
posted some of the love
they've received from fans including
this letter from nine-year-old dexter
who wrote saying
i'm proud of you you will always be a
hero and from 11 year old alfie who said
i admire you and so should the rest of
the world
and another letter that said you should
be proud you made it to the finals you
tried your hardest
and that's very much good enough
messages of love and support there from
some soccers some of soccer's youngest
and perhaps wisest fans that 11 year old
alfie also wrote he said recently i've
been doing bad with my social anxiety
so my mom bought me your book and it
changed me
oh wow and this is one of the things
about marcus rashford he's done
an enormous amount of community support
he helped raise more than 27
million dollars to tackle food poverty
these are all these guys have been very
involved in the community
people should read a statement it's very
powerful he said i've been playing this
over
in my sleep he said i can do panel i can
do this in my sleep why it didn't work
that day
i'm so sorry he of course is beating
himself up yeah but you know how painful
this must be for all of them
yeah and i'm glad to see the outpouring
of support absolutely johnson prince
william speaking out
and this is this hurts in a way teaching
a lesson to these young kids and these
guys are leaders beyond the field you
know marcus absolutely yes topped the
uk's giving list
the youngest person to ever do that 23
years old the most charitable person or
family relative to his wealth it's just
incredible yeah
that's how people remember that yeah